[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ich euch fragen würde was
eigentlich die NATO ist würden mir die
meisten von euch sicherlich eine ganz
klare Antwort geben können ein
Militärbündnis zwischen verschiedenen
Ländern das gegründet wurde um die
ehemalige Sowjetunion zu bekämpfen
tatsächlich zählt die NATO die
Organisation der des
nordatlantikvertrages bereits 31
Verbündete Länder 32 wenn ihr Schweden
mitzählt mit anderen Worten wir sprechen
hier über das mit Abstand größte
Militärbündnis der Welt und ich denke
wir alle kennen die militärische Stärke
vieler Armeen der Länder die diesem Club
angehören da wären z.B die allmächtigen
US of A aber was wäre wenn ich euch
sagen würde dass es in der NATO ein Land
gibt das überhaupt kein Militär hat
sicherlich würdet ihr euch fragen wie
kann es in einem Militärbündnis wie der
NATO ein Land ohne Streitkräfte geben
nun ja das ist der Fall unseres heutigen
Protagonisten
Island diese ferne Insel zwischen Europa
und Amerika mit kaum 370.000 Einwohnern
die hauptsächlich von der
aluminiumverhüttung der Fischerei und
dem Tourismus lebt ist das einzige
natoland ohne Militär und tatsächlich
glauben viele dass dies der Hauptgrund
dafür ist warum Island das friedlichste
Land der Welt ist eine Position die ihr
seit mehr als im Jahrzehnt inner hat
aber vielleicht fragt ihr euch wie ist
es überhaupt möglich dass es kein
Militär hat nun es ist sicherlich nicht
das erste Land und wird auch nicht das
letzte sein das über keine eigenen
Streitkräfte verfügt es gibt auf dieser
Welt mehr als 30 Länder die keine eigene
Armee haben aber natürlich reden wir
hier von Ländern wie Andorra Monaco und
Panama sie alle ein dass sie nur eine
sehr kleine Bevölkerung haben dennoch
wäre es logisch zu denken dass ein Land
in einem Militärbündnis ist weil es ein
eigenes Militär hat oder und wisst ihr
was das über überraschendste an der
ganzen Sache ist nun dass Island lange
Zeit ein sehr wichtiges Mitglied der
NATO war und wie ist das möglich nun ihr
müsst verstehen dass Island zwar über
keine eigenen Streitkräfte verfügt aber
über einen anderen sehr wertvollen
Vorteil seine geografische Lage während
des Kalten Kriegs wurde es sogar zu
einem der begehrtesten Orte für die
großen Supermächte aber warum was ist so
wichtig an seiner Lage auf der Weltkarte
wie hat Island es geschafft sich seine
Lage zu Nutze zu machen wer verteidigt
diese abgelegene Insel im Falle eines
Angriffs oder gar einer Invasion
überhaupt und welche Rolle spielt Island
in der Arktis die von Russland zunehmend
militarisiert wird heute werden wir all
diese spannenden Fragen natürlich
beantworten und zwar gleich nach der
knackigen Werbebotschaft unseres
Sponsors blinkist denn die Berliner
Firma blinkkist hat mit ihrem Beitrag
nicht nur das heutige Video möglich
gemacht nein wir nutzen Ihre App auch
selbst um täglich unseren eigenen
Wissenshorizont zu erweitern vielleicht
fragt ihr euch ja manchmal wie wir es
schaffen so viel Wissen aus
verschiedenen Bereichen miteinander in
unseren Videos zu verknüpfen nun der
Schlüssel dazu ist vor allem lesen lesen
und manchmal auch hören Artikel Analysen
Videos Podcasts und vor allem Bücher mit
Grundlagen wissen das notwendig ist um
diese Informationen zu einem Gesamtbild
verknüpfen zu können aber was wenn man
gar nicht die Zeit dazu hat so viele
verschiedene Bücher zu lesen und genau
dann ist man bei blinkest richtig denn
es verschafft einem nicht nur mehr Zeit
sondern motiviert auch durch die
unterhaltsame Aufmachung blinkist bringt
das Wichtigste aus mehr als 5000
Sachbücher und Podcasts auf dein Handy
und dann erlebst du ein ten wissensbost
anstatt Stunden in die Lektüre eines
Buches zu stecken und es dann vielleicht
gar nicht zu Ende zu lesen ziehst du dir
Null kom nichts die immer sehr angenehm
und locker geschriebene blinkest Version
rein man merkt dass da echte Profis und
Talente am Werk sind stell dir vor wir
würden ein wertvolles aber langes Buch
in ein knackiges und leicht verdauliches
visualpolitik Video Gießen nun genau das
macht blinkist ein Beispiel sind Bücher
von Autoren mit denen man vielleicht
nicht immer einer Meinung ist womit aber
kann man sein Horizont besser erweitern
als mit Information die eben nicht aus
der eigenen stammen mir ist z.B das Buch
kein Kapitalismus ist auch keine Lösung
der ehemaligen tassautorin Ulrike
Hermann aufgefallen auch hier habe ich
mir gesagt die TAS ist ja nicht gerade
mein Leib und magenblatt Rezensenten auf
Amazon haben das Buch auch dafür
kritisiert langatmig zu sein muss ich
mir das also wirklich antun andererseits
hat mich schon interessiert was da drin
steht tja und dank der Fesseln
geschriebenen blinkistfassung konnte ich
innerhalb von 25 Minuten herausfinden
dass dieses Werk zumindest in der
blinkest Version mein Horizont durchaus
bereichern konnte solides Wissen dass
ich ohne blinkes sicher verpasst hätte
kurz gesagt diese App wird mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit auch dein Leben
bereichern egal für welches Thema du
dich gerade interessierst die Auswahl
und das Spektrum sind wirklich riesig
von Finanzen über Wissenschaft Politik
Karriere bis zu den klassischen
Ratgeberthemen um sein Leben zu
optimieren aber man kann mit blinkes
nicht nur sich selbst sondern auch
seineem lieben bereichern es hat nämlich
vor kurzem eine ganz neue Funktion
namens blinkest spaces eingeführt damit
kannst du deine lieblingsblinks mit
deinen Freunden und Kollegen teilen und
dann mit ihn diskutieren wie in einem
Buchclub das coole daran ist dass du
blinkist basic User in deinen space
einladen kannst und diese dort dann alle
Titel lesen und hören können auch wenn
sie normalerweise nur für Premium
Mitglieder zugänglich wären und das ist
noch nicht alles als visualpolitik
Zuschauer bekommst du über den Link in
der Beschreibung nicht nur zwei
Mitgliedschaften zum Preis von einer
sondern obenrein noch 25% Rabatt auf
blinkist Premium also zögere nicht
besorg dir jetzt gleich die kostenlose 7
Tage Testversion über den Link unter
diesem Video und fang dann gleich damit
an deinen BS schat zu bereichern und
wenn du das erledigt hast können wir
sofort zur Beantwortung unserer
spannenden Fragen streiten
[Musik]
aufgepasst die Macht der
Geografie ich möchte euch eine Frage
stellen was fällt euch als erstes ein
wenn ich Island erwähne vielleicht die
wikinge vielleicht Vulkane deren
Aschewolken Europa zum Stillstand
bringen können ja diese beiden Dinge
sind sehr charakteristisch für diese
Insel aber aber abgesehen davon reden
wir über ein Land das in der modernen
Geschichte eher unbemerkt geblieben ist
schließlich handelte es sich in der
Vergangenheit um eine entfernte Insel
des Königreichs Dänemark die von Armut
Hungersnöten Epidemien und sogar
gelegentlichen Vulkanausbrüchen
heimgesucht wurde ja das Leben auf
Island war wahrlich kein Zuckerschlecken
allerdings sollte sich das Schicksal
dieses Ortes in der Mitte des 20
Jahrhunderts grundlegend ändern und zwar
als zunächst Großbritannien und dann die
USA die Insel zwischen 1940 und 44
besetzten um NAZ Deutschland im
nördlichen Atlantik entgegenzutreten für
die Isländer war dies unvermeidlich da
sie 1869 ihre eigenen Streitkräfte
abgeschafft hatten tatsache ist dass
Island im Laufe der Zeit und vor allem
im 20 Jahrhundert zu einem strategischen
Punkt wurde und das sahen die USA sehr
deutlich aus diesem Grund begann Unkel
Sam schon bald über den Beitritt Islands
zur NATO zu
verhandeln nachdem Island 1944 seine
Unabhängigkeit erlangt hatte wurde es
sich schnell seiner privilegierten
geostrategischen Lage als Wächter des
Nordatlantiks bewusst was reerweg
allerdings auch klar war war die eigene
Wehrlosigkeit und die Abhängigkeit von
einer fremden Besatzung der Weg war also
vorgezeichnet zusammen mit anderen
europäischen Ländern den USA und Kanada
Gründungsmitglied der NATO zu werden die
zu einem der Grundpfeiler ihrer
Verteidigung werden würde nach dem
Ausbruch des koreakkriegs stieg
allerdings auf der Insel die Angst vor
einem Angriff der Sowjetunion sprunghaft
an island brauchte dringend
Militärpersonal auf seinem Territorium
der salb schloss es 1951 ein
verteidigungsabkommen mit den USA ab das
bis heute in Kraft ist und die andere
tragende SLE der isländischen Sicherheit
darstellt von diesem Zeitpunkt an bis
2006 war die sogenannte Icelandic
Defense Force mit 1350 US-Soldaten und
weiteren 100 Zivilisten des
US-Verteidigungsministeriums auf dem
marinestüzpunkt keflerweg in Island
stationiert endlich war Island sicher
das Land der unaussprechlichen Vulkane
bekam was es wollte es nutzte seine
geographische Lage um schützt zu werden
aber das war noch lange nicht
alles denn was wäre wenn ich euch
verraten würde dass die isländischen
Regierungen zu dieser Zeit ziemlich
hinterhältig waren was würdet ihr denken
wenn ich sage dass Erpressung eine
ziemlich typische Taktik der Isländer
[Applaus]
war wollt ihr ein Beispiel zwischen den
50er und 70er Jahren kämpfte Island mit
Großbritannien um fischereizonen was als
kabeljaukriege be wurde Island dehnte
seine zon immer weiter aus ohne mit dem
Vereinigten Königreich zu verhandeln was
zu starken Spannungen führte und in
diesem ganzen Chaos haben es die USA nie
gewagt sich auf die Seite der Britten zu
stellen Islands geopolitische Lage war
einfach zu wichtig um die in der Region
sehr aktive Sowjetunion im Auge zu
behalten wie Ihr auf dieser Karte sehen
könnt ist es Island gelungen seine
ausschließliche Wirtschaftszone und
seine fischereizonen auf 200 Seemeilen
auszuweihen und ja ich weiß was ihr
denkt aber diese Grenze ist doch die die
gleiche die für alle Küstenstaaten gilt
oder ja und da habt ihr recht allerdings
ist das kurios an dieser ganzen
Geschichte wie schnell sie es geschafft
haben ihre ausschließliche
Wirtschaftszone praktisch um das
Zehnfache zu
[Applaus]
erweitern tja allerdings sollte Ihnen
das Glück bald ausgehen die Sowjetunion
kollabierte und der kalte Krieg endete
die kommunistische Bedrohung war
plötzlich verschwunden und mit ihr auch
das Bedürfnis der Amerikaner einen
Stützpunkt auf Island zu haben daher
begannen die USA ihre Truppen von der
Insel abzuziehen sodass 2006 keine
amerikanischen Stiefel mehr auf
isländischem Boden standen die
isländischen Verteidigungskräfte wurden
aufgelöst und der Stützpunkt geflwg
wurde der isländischen Regierung
übergeben die ihn zum wichtigsten
internationalen Flughafen des Landes
machte das verteidigungsabkommen mit den
USA aus dem Jahr 1951 blieb in Kraft und
gilt auch heute noch aber es gibt kein
Militärpersonal mehr auf der Insel das
ändert allerdings nichts an der Tatsache
dass der Abzug des us-persals ein
riesiges Sicherheitsvakuum hinterließ
zumindest psychologisch gesehen es blieb
das Gefühl dass der Inselstaat all die
geostrategische Bedeutung verloren hatte
die er jahrzehntelang hatte ausnutzen
können und genau aus diesem Grund begann
Island zu handeln rewig begann die
Verantwortung für seine eigene
Sicherheit in die eigene Hand zu nehmen
aber wie sollten Sie das ohne eigenes
Militär tun nun haltet euch
[Musik]
fest eisige
Spannungen nur selten finden wir Länder
die mehr als 60 Jahre gebraucht haben um
die Sicherheit ihres Territoriums
gesetzlich zu regeln denn genau das ist
der Fall Islands schließlich ist
Sicherheit normalerweise eine der
obersten Prioritäten für jedes Land das
überleben will wie kann ein Land das
seine eigenen Grenzen nicht schützen
kann überhaupt überleben nun die
Realität ist dass Island dafür eben die
US-Truppen hatte und zwar so lange bis
sie sie nicht mehr hatten als die
US-Truppen die Insel verließen und
Island die neue Realität erkannte
dauerte es natürlich nicht lange bis es
handelte es Schloss Kooperationsabkommen
mit anderen natopartnern ab gründete
2008 die isländische
verteidigungsagentur die 2011 allerdings
wegen Geldmangels geschlossen wurde aber
immerhin verabschiedete es 2008 ein
verteidigungsgesetz und 2016 seine
nationale Sicherheitspolitik sie haben
also nicht tatenlos zugesehen sondern
zumindest etwas auf dem Papier
vollbracht und aus diesem Grund hat
Island heute eine Küstenwache die zwar
schon seit 2018 besteht aber noch nie so
groß war wie heute sie verfügt über rund
200 Mitarbeiter vier Schiffe und
mittelgroße Hubschrauber außerdem wurden
seit dem Abzug der USA die
polizeieinrichtung des Landes gestärkt
und als ob das noch nicht genug wäre hat
Island sogar eine paramilitärische
Einheit die sogenannte crisis response
unit ist eine kleine Truppe die für
internationale friedenserhaltende
Maßnahmen bereit steht aber Achtung es
gibt noch mehr zu beachten Island hat
auch zwei entscheidende Vorteile für die
Nato und zwar vor allem sein
Luftverteidigungssystem das vier
komplexe Radarsysteme betreibt die als
frühwarnysteme für die NATO benütten
dienen und das zweite Pfund das es in
die NATO mitbringt ist se eigenes
Territorium und Klima diese nutzt die
NATO nämlich für harte Militärübungen
bekannt als northern Viking aber okay
sein wir ehrlich Islands
verteidigungskapazitäten sind immer noch
ziemlich beschränkt vor allem wenn man
die großen sicherheitsherausforderungen
berücksichtigt die heute wieder auf dem
Schirm sind und diese schwachen
militärischen Fähigkeiten sind vor allem
dann besutniserregend wenn wir uns
anschauen was an einem der Orte passiert
der Island am nächsten liegt und der in
den let leten zwei Jahrzehnten enorm an
strategischer Bedeutung gewonnen hat wir
sprechen natürlich über die
Arktis die Arktis hat in den letzten
Jahren vor allem aus einem Grund an
Bedeutung gewonnen aufgrund der
Eisschmelze das verstärkte sommerliche
abschmelzende der Eismassen ermöglicht
die Entstehung und Festigung neuer
Handelsrouten und öffnet die Möglichkeit
die riesigen Ressourcen zu erforschen
wir sprechen immerhin von bis zu 30%
aller weltweiten Erdgasreserven und 13%
der weltweiten Ölreserven und aus diesem
Grund wird die Arktis vor allem von
einem Akteur zunehmend militarisiert
nehmlich von Russland denn russland hat
außerordentlich große Interesse in der
Arktis immerhin werden dort 80% seines
Erdgases und 17% seines Öls gefördert
außerdem beherbergt die Arktis die
größte russische marineflotte die
Nordmeerflotte und den größten Zugang
zum offenen Meer kein Wunder also dass
Russland die Arktis wie kein anderes
Land hochrüstet und dies hat wiederum
dazu geführt dass auch die NATO die Zahl
ihrer Stützpunkte in der Region
verdreifacht hat aber wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt ist Russland nicht das
einzige Land dass sich für die Aktes
interessiert auch China das selbst keine
arktische Nation wie Schweden Norwegen
oder Island ist hat starke Interessen in
dieser Region Peking verfügt in diesen
drei Ländern bereits über zivile
Stützpunkte die von seinen
Geheimdiensten genutzt werden können das
Interesse des asiatischen riesen an
diesem Gebiet liegt allerdings nicht so
sehr im militärischen Bereich sonder vor
allem in seinem kommerziellen poten
[Musik]
ihr müsst nämlich verstehen dass das
Hauptziel Pekings in der Region darin
besteht den nördlichen seeeweg zu
fördern um die Zeit und die Kosten für
den Seetransport zu reduzieren dies
dient nämlich der eigenen Sicherheit
Chinas über diese Route kann China auch
sicherstellen dass die Ladungen die es
in seinen Häfen aufnehmen muss weder in
der Straße von Malaka noch im Indischen
Ozean unterbrochen werden denn dort ist
es mit einer Vielzahl von Gegnern
konfrontiert wie z.B Indien deshalb hat
China Russland trotz der Sanktion und
unterstützt um diesen Weg wirklich
stabil zu machen und es überrascht nicht
dass die USA angesichts einer solchen
Möglichkeiten nicht außen vorbleiben
können es stimmt dass ankel Sams
Interesse an der Arktis bis vor kurzem
eher gering war aber mit dem Amtsantritt
von Trump als Präsident gewann das Thema
wieder an Bedeutung z.B wurde 2018 die
zweite Flotte der USA wieder aufgestellt
und 2020 führte die amerikanische macht
mehr als 20 Militärübungen in der Arktis
durch und als ob das noch nicht genug
wäre haben wir in letzter Zeit
Nachrichten wie diese gefunden Island
genehmig den Besuch von US atomuboten
diese Nachricht ist aufschlussreicher
als sie scheint man könnte meinen dass
die Rolle islands in den
Auseinandersetzungen der Großmächte in
der Arktis nicht allzu relevant sei die
Realität ist allerdings dass die Rolle
dieser dünn besesiedelten Insel ohne
eigenes Militär in diesen ganzen
strategischen Puzzle entscheidend ist
oder anders ausgedrückt Island hat seine
geopolitische Bedeutung wieder
zurückgewonnen und warum genau und das
werden wir jetzt
herausfinden
Island Hütter der
Lücke während der letzten anderthalb
Jahre konnten wir alle sehr gut
beobachten wie Russland den Großteil
seiner Anstrengungen auf die Invasion
der Ukraine konzentriert hat manche
mögen denken dass es dabei andere
geopolitische Ziele vernachlässigte und
das mag auch so sein aber in der Arktis
ist das sicher nicht der Fall die eisige
Region im Norden hat für Putin nach wie
vor absolute Priorität weshalb sie trotz
allem immer noch stark militarisiert ist
ihr würdet natürlich denken dass Moskau
wenn es so viele Ressourcen in der
Ukraine gebunden hat nicht an die Arktis
denken kann oder nun nichts könnte von
der Wahrheit weiter entfernt sein in
diesem Gebiet wurden die russischen
militärischen Fähigkeiten Z seeunder in
der Luft kaum reduziert und auch am
Boden nur geringfügig und genau das
macht die natostaaten und ihre
Verbündeten äußerst wachsam da Russlands
Präsenz in der Region kaum zu ignorieren
ist hat Island nicht gerade oft daran
gedacht Moskau direkt die Stirn zu
bieten ihre Beziehungen haben sich sogar
positiv entwickelt 2013 haben sie sich
z.B verpflichtet beim Schutz der Arktis
und bei der Forschung enger
zusammenzuarbeiten außerdem haben sie
Vereinbarungen über Fischerei Energie
und Tourismus getroffen aber all das hat
die Isländer nicht dazu gebracht ihre
internationalen Verpflichtungen zu
vergessen 2014 zögerte Island z.B keine
Sekunde Russlands Übergriffe in der
Ukraine zu verurteilen als die krimüberf
fallen und annektiert wurde und schloss
sich den westlichen Sanktionen an obwohl
die eigene Fischereiindustrie darunter
leiden würde danach wurden Nachrichten
wie diese übrigens alltäglich 20 Februar
2015 russische Bomber im isländischen
Luftraum gesichtet Island beklagt dass
russische Bomber eine Gefahr für zivile
Flugzeuge darstellen reikwig sagt dass
drei russische tupof tu160
Militärflugzeuge beim letzten
Zwischenfall am Dienstag zu nah an einem
Passagierflugzeug geflogen sind als
Russland Anfang 2022 erneut die Ukraine
überfiel verurteilte und sanktionierte
Island dies ebenso wie 2014 und obwohl
Island kein eigenes Militär hat und es
sich nicht leisten kann Soldaten an die
Freund zu schicken hat es die Ukraine
auf andere Weise unterstützt es hat
unter anderem drei feldlatarette
gespendet zehn öltransporter gekauft und
3000 Flüchtlinge aufgenommen aber all
das sagt uns nicht viel über die neue
geopolitische Bedeutung die Island in
letzter Zeit erlangt hat worum geht es
also genau nun um nichts weniger als
seine zentrale Position in einem ganz
bestimmten Raum der sogenannten
giuglücke die für Grönland Island und
Großbritannien steht die giug oder
gioglücke bezieht sich auf den Raum der
die norwegische See vom Nordatlantik
trennt und von Grönland über Island bis
nach Großbritannien
reicht diese Region hatte im Kalten
Krieg eine besondere Bedeutung da sie
als blokadepunkt des Operationsgebiet
der sowjetischen Nordflotte vom
atlantikgebiet der NATO trennte mit
anderen Worten sie dite als Barriere
gegen die sowjetischen Streitkräfte aus
diesem Grund wurde giog zu einem der am
stärksten beobachteten Gebiete der Welt
wobei Island eine besonders wichtige
Rolle spielte da es einen fast
peripheren Blick auf eine weitreichende
Kontrolle über die Region
hatte und heute meine Lieben Zuschauer
hat Island seine relevante Rolle in
einer Zeit wieder erlangt in der
Russland wieder eindeutlich feindlich
gesindnt ist mit nuklearen und
konventionellen u-bootpatrouillen nicht
nur in der arktischen Region sondern
auch eben in der
giuglücke die mögliche Rückkehr zu einer
dem Kalten Krieg ähnlichen Situation mit
U-Booten die um Island herum stationiert
sind und strategischen bomberflügen die
nun wieder drohen hat Island eine
hervorragende Gelegenheit geboten erneut
das militärische Interesse der USA und
der NATO auf sich zu ziehen und so in
unsicheren Zeiten territoriale
Sicherheit von seinen NATO Verbündeten
und vor allem von der amerikanischen
Großmacht zu erlangen ihr seht Island
ist der beste Beweis dafür dass ihr kein
eigenes Militär braucht um einflussreich
zu sein Island ist auch ohne eigenes
Militär äußerst sicher und wohlhabend
mehr noch es ist vielleicht eines der
besten Beispiele dafür dass ihr selbst
mit den schlechtesten Karten Wunder
bewirken könnt wenn ihr gut spielt
Island ist auf das geopolitische
schachpit zurückgekehrt angeheizt durch
einen neuen Konflikt zwischen dem Westen
und Russland und es könnte jetzt mit
einer von Putin stark militarisierten
Arktis eine noch zentrale Rolle bei der
Überwachung der geoglücke spielen als
während des Kalten Krieges wir werden
dieses von den Medien oft
vernachlässigte Thema daheim Auge
behalten und euch auf dem laufenden also
vergesst nicht unseren Kanal zu
abonnieren falls es euch auch
interessiert aber an dieser Stelle sind
die Fragen erstmal an euch gerichtet
stehen wir vor dem Beginn einer weiteren
langen Periode der strategischen
Bedeutung Islands wird Island wieder
einmal eigennützige Spielchen mit seinen
Partner spielen wie es das während des
Kalten Kriegs getan hat wird es
angesichts eines zunehmend präsenten
Russlands in der Arktis eine größere
ausländische Militärpräsenz fordern wie
immer sind wir auf eure Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht etwas dabei
gelernt habt Fall ja gebt den bitte ein
Like und teilt es mit euren Freunden um
es mit ihnen zu diskutieren natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
freiwillige Spende von euch mit uns h
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung dem
Video macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald